Joey used 0.43 2 pounds of cheese to
make mac and cheese for dinner we could
also call this 430 mm pounds of cheese
to make mac and cheese for dinner
round the amount of cheese to the
nearest tenth so the amount of cheese
once again is zero point four three two
pounds and just remember the places here
this is going to be this is 4/10 so
that's the tenths place this is the
hundredths place and that that's an S
there so tenths hundredths and this is
right over here is thousands thousands
place so we want to round to the nearest
tenth so we're going to round to the
nearest tenth we go one place to the
right if it's 5 or larger we round up
this would become a five if it's less
than five so it's it's less than five
which is the case here we're going to
round down to just four tenths even so
because 3 is less than 5 we are going to
round down and we're going to get zero
point four zero zero or we could write
that as zero point four or we could
write that as four tenths of a pound
let's do another one
Eliza's pet snail traveled to point one
nine seven meters in one day round the
distance to the nearest hundredth so
pause this video and see if you can do
that round 2 the distance to the nearest
hundredth so it's two point one nine
seven this is the hundredths place right
over here and so if we're going to round
to the nearest hundredth we're going to
go one place to the right if this one
place to the right is five or greater
we're going to round up and seven is
five or greater so we are going to round
round up now this is interesting because
if you round a nine up you get to ten
but you can't put a whole ten right over
here so one way to think about is you
19 here and so if you round up you're
going to go to a twenty and so or
doesn't way to think about it if you
round the nine up you're going to go to
the next tenth so this is going to be
two point we have you could say you
could view this as 1900 or 1900s and
seven thousand and so now we're going to
round up to 20 hundredths so two point
two zero we're rounding to the nearest
hundredth
which you could write is two point two
but it'd make it clear that you're
rounding to the nearest hundredth you're
going to write to point two zero and
later in your life this actually might
matter to show how much what to actually
show what you are rounding to let's do
another example here Cassandra spends
six point seven five hours each day at
school
round the amount of time to the nearest
hour alright so six point seven five so
you might be a little confused and
actually I encourage you to pause the
video again and try to solve it on your
own so you might be a little confused
cuz they're not saying round it to the
nearest tenth or hundredth or one or ten
or hundred they're saying to the nearest
hour but in this case the hour is the
ones place so if we're going to round to
the nearest hour this is another way of
saying round to the nearest one so we're
going to round to the nearest one we go
one place to the right we go to look at
the tenths place if it's five or larger
we round up well seven is five or larger
so we round up to the next hour which is
going to be seven so seven hours if this
was six point four nine nine nine nine
once again if we're rounding to the
nearest hour we go one place to the
right doesn't matter that we have all
these nines here we'd say hey look 4 is
less than 5 therefore we should round
down round down and you would round down
to the next hour well the next hour
that's below six point four nine nine
nine nine nine nine nine nine is six
hours but in this case we had a seven in
the tenths place which is definitely
greater than or equal to five and so
round up to the next hour which is seven
hours